the haunted house looks stupid i don't  even mean fun stupid like a lot stand i  mean annoying stupid like the scary  movie franchise and those two dumbasses  who made epic movie and meet the  spartans i did laugh at one joke though  just one that was a funny one watch the  trailer but other than that one clip all  the jokes seemed rehashed from the scary  movie recyclable bin the very least it  wasn't a bunch of dumb slapstick comedy  where people are getting hit no wait a  minute oh yeah it does that too when i  first heard about this i thought marlon  williams was making some type of  comeback i thought he was like man all  you [ __ ] tried making scary  movie without me and damon  i'm going to show you how it's done but  all this looks like is a low budget  version of scary movie 2. i'm still  going to watch it because i had faith in  marlin oh and by the way scary movie 5  looks like [ __ ] too ryan wright thinks  the haunted house will get it wrong